Y si te dijera que la Guerra de Irak ha sido
quizás la mayor estupidez estratégica de
Estados Unidos en los últimos 30 años.
Al menos teniendo en cuenta eso que se llama
la realpolitik.
Pensadlo un momento: ¿Cuáles son las principales
amenazas para los intereses de Washington?
China, Rusia, Corea del Norte e Irán.
Recordad que Irán es toda una potencia regional
en Oriente Próximo.
Tienen casi 90 millones de habitantes y recursos
naturales a punta pala, con las segundas mayores
reservas de gas natural del mundo y las cuartas
de petróleo.
En pocas palabras, Irán ocupa una posición
estratégica fundamental en Oriente Próximo.
Y además, Teherán está a punto de desarrollar
su propia bomba atómica.
Pues bien, teniendo que lidiar con semejante
adversario en este rincón del planeta, resulta
que el mayor muro de contención frente al
expansionismo iraní no era otro que Saddam
Hussein.
El Irak de Saddam era una dictadura salvaje,
sí, pero absolutamente antiraní.
Y entonces llega Estados Unidos hace 20 años,
y no se le ocurre mejor cosa que dejar Irak
en bandeja de plata a Irán.
Ale, toma Jamenei, para ti todo.
Puede que os parezca que estoy exagerando.
Pero 20 años después, os aseguro que así
han sido las cosas.
De hecho, seguramente muchos recordáis que
cuando comenzó la guerra de Irak se pasaban
memes como este:
Bueno, pues por extraño que parezca, esto
es exactamente lo que ha pasado.
Porque hoy en día hay una democracia en Irak.
Ahora bien: ¿quién se ha hecho con el poder
en la democracia iraquí?
Pues ni más ni menos que los líderes chiíes
más próximos a Irán.
Es más, ¿os acordáis de Qasem Soleimani,
el comandante de la Fuerza Quds?
Pues bien, este general iraní campaba a sus
anchas por Irak, organizando las milicias
chiíes que operan en el país.
De hecho, Estados Unidos logra acabar con
el general Soleimani en Bagdad.
Y para que veáis cómo están las cosas,
la capital iraquí ha sumado un nuevo lugar
de interés a sus guías turísticas.
Mirad:
(Los restos del ataque con drones de Estados
Unidos que mataron a Qasem Soleimani y Abu
Mahdi al-Muhandis en Irak el año pasado ahora
son un sitio conmemorativo en la carretera
del aeropuerto de Bagdad.)
Hay que reconocer que en Turkmenistán tienen
más gusto para hacer monumentos.
Pero bueno, volviendo a lo importante, el
resumen es que Irán representa una amenaza
cada vez mayor a medida que cada vez está
más cerca de tener la bomba atómica.
Y ahora encima está expandiendo su influencia
sobre Irak, el cuarto país exportador de
petróleo del mundo y el segundo mayor dentro
de la OPEP.
Sin embargo, amigos, la situación podría
estar a punto de cambiar a favor de Estados
Unidos.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Hasta qué punto
podría evaporarse la influencia iraní sobre
Irak?
¿Qué papel jugará este señor que ahora
mismo estáis viendo en pantalla y que parece
más un anuncio de La Venganza de los Sith
que un líder político iraquí?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes… vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
T1(ENEMIGOS ÍNTIMOS)
Hay 3 ideas claves que quiero recordaros.
La primera, que ya os hemos mencionado un
montón de veces, es que dentro del mundo
islámico se vive una Guerra Fría eterna
entre las dos corrientes principales del Islam:
el sunismo y el chiismo.
La pugna entre ambas ramas de la religión
musulmana proviene del año 632, cuando se
decidió quien debía suceder a Mahoma, así
que a estas alturas no esperéis un acuerdo.
Alrededor del 80% de los musulmanes son suníes.
Sin embargo, amigos, la República Islámica
de Irán es territorio completamente chiita.
En menor medida también lo es Irak, donde
los chíies son el 65% de la población frente
al 30% suní.
Y esto nos lleva a la segunda idea importante:
el Irak de Saddam Hussein era un país gobernado
por una élite sunita a pesar de la mayoría
social chiita.
Para la tercera idea es mejor echar un vistazo
al mapa:
Aquí podéis comprobar que Irak e Irán son
dos países que además de tener un nombre
muy parecido son vecinos.
Y además de los que no se llevaban nada bien.
Estuvieron enfrentados durante décadas, desde
que el socialismo árabe se impuso en Irak
y propugnó un nacionalismo que incluía reivindicaciones
territoriales sobre Irán.
De hecho, Saddam Hussein invadió Irán a
principios de los años 80.
Luego Irán lanzó su contraofensiva sobre
Irak.
La guerra duró 8 años y no sirvió para
nada; las fronteras no cambiaron.
Ambos países quedaron arruinados mientras
provocaban aproximadamente un millón de muertes.
Luego vendría la invasión de Kuwait, la
Guerra del Golfo y la invasión de Irak en
2003.
Es entonces cuando nuestro hombre empieza
a cobrar protagonismo.
Él es Muqtada Al-Sadr.
(Muqtada Al-Sadr es un clérigo hijo del Gran
Ayatolá Mohamed Sadeq al-Sadr.
Su padre fue una autoridad religiosa importante
para los chíies de Irak, condenados a pertenecer
a las clases sociales más desfavorecidas
durante la dura represión ejercida por el
régimen sunita de Saddam Hussein.
Como ayatolá se dedicó a predicar sobre
cuestiones sociales y económicas que afectaban
a la vida de las personas, por lo que también
se convirtió en un referente político para
los chiíes.
Su éxito provocó que fuera asesinado por
el régimen de Saddam en 1999.)
Los chiíes eran la principal oposición al
régimen de Saddam.
Después de su caída, algunos de sus líderes
cooperaron con Estados Unidos para trabajar
juntos en la creación del nuevo Irak.
No fue el caso de Muqtada Al-Sadr, que se
opuso de forma radical a la ocupación estadounidense.
Muchos chiíes que ya habían seguido al gran
ayatolá Al-Sadr vieron en su hijo un símbolo
de la resistencia frente al invasor.
De este modo Muqtada Al-Sadr se convirtió
en uno de los líderes más conocidos de la
insurgencia iraquí, con gran poder e influencia
en el centro y sur del país, así como en
Bagdad, en el suburbio de Al-Zaura de la capital,
hoy conocido como Ciudad Al-Sadr.
Pues bien, para combatir contra las tropas
invasoras, Muqtada Al-Sadr creó una milicia,
el Ejército de Al-Mahdi.
Operativa entre 2003 y 2008, esta milicia
reforzó el status de Muqtada Al-Sadr como
uno de los hombres más influyentes del nuevo
Irak.
Sin embargo, amigos, este no era el mejor
camino para llegar al poder.
Porque como os decía antes, Estados Unidos
instauró en Irak una democracia.
Y claro, en la población iraquí los chiíes
son mayoría.
Así que el ayatolá iraquí Ali al-Sistani
hizo un llamamiento a los diferentes partidos
chiíes para que presentaran una lista única
a las primeras elecciones libres.
Muqtada Al-Sadr y el resto de líderes chiíes
accedieron y la Alianza Iraquí Unida se hizo
con la victoria en las elecciones de 2005.
(La Alianza Iraquí Unida traicionó rápidamente
su nombre.
En 2007 la coalición saltaba por los aires,
dando lugar a una nueva pugna para hacerse
con el liderazgo político chií.
El principal beneficiado fue el primer ministro
Nuri al-Maliki.
Antiguamente exiliado en Irán, desde donde
consiguió apoyo financiero para la oposición
islamista a Saddam Hussein, Nuri al-Maliki
incrementó su popularidad entre los iraquíes
desde el cargo de primer ministro al mejorar
la seguridad dentro del país.)
Muqtada Al-Sadr se fue moviendo en política
de forma pragmática.
Concedió o retiró el apoyo del Movimiento
Sadrista en función de la influencia que
pudiera conseguir sobre los diferentes Ministerios.
Su ideología tiene dos pilares: el pensamiento
religioso chií y el nacionalismo iraquí.
Por ello siempre se ha mostrado contrario
a las injerencias extranjeras, vengan de Estados
Unidos o de Irán.
Las tropas estadounidenses se retiraron en
diciembre de 2011.
Sin embargo, una nueva amenaza comenzó a
extenderse sobre Irak en 2014.
El Daesh, el Estado Islámico, puso en jaque
al nuevo Estado iraquí.
Seguidores de una versión extrema del Islam
suni, extendieron los dominios de su califato
hasta Faluya, a apenas 69 kilómetros de Bagdad.
Ante la incapacidad del Ejército iraquí
para hacerles frente, las distintas fuerzas
chiíes formaron sus propias milicias paramilitares.
También Muqtada Al-Sadr, que recuperó a
su antigua milicia del Ejército de Al-Mahdi.
Después de 3 años de guerra consiguieron
la victoria.
A pesar de ello, las milicias paramilitares
chiíes, que cuentan con el respaldo de Irán,
no se han disuelto.
Por su parte, Muqtada Al-Sadr emprendió una
estrategia de oposición al Gobierno que le
ha dado resultado: el Movimiento Sadrista
llegó a convertirse en el grupo más grande
del Parlamento de Irak.
¿Cómo lo ha conseguido?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2(¡ÁBRETE, SÉSAMO!)
La democracia iraquí se parece tanto a las
occidentales que en apenas una década la
gente ya estaba harta de sus políticos.
Desde 2018 la participación en las elecciones
se desplomó al 44%.
Mientras sus rivales han caído en el descredito,
Muqtada al-Sadr ha sabido mantener a sus fieles
e incrementar sus votantes.
Esto se ha traducido de momento en una mayor
influencia sobre los asuntos iraquís.
De hecho, en las negociaciones parlamentarias
ha obtenido su cuota de empleos en las empresas
públicas para ofrecérselos a sus seguidores.
La creación de estas redes clientelares ha
ido fortaleciendo y ampliando su base social.
Muqtada al-Sadr ha pasado así de ser un simple
señor de la guerra a un maestro de las artes
políticas.
Algo bastante sorprendente viendo que en los
últimos años Irak está dando por fin alguna
buena noticia.
(La Zona Verde de Bagdad reabre al público
después de 16 años)
La Zona Verde era la única zona segura dentro
de la propia Bagdad.
Es donde se ubica la Embajada estadounidense,
así como diversos edificios gubernamentales.
Durante todos estos años ha sido una zona
blindada porque desde la invasión estadounidense
Irak era un auténtico polvorín.
Que ahora vuelva a estar abierta al público
es la mejor señal de que la situación vuelve
a ser relativamente tranquila.
Y más de uno estará pensando, pero a ver
Fonseca, ¿entonces a qué viene tanto descontento?
Pues bien, la cuestión es que muchos iraquíes
están viendo cómo sus gobernantes están
más pendientes de atender los deseos de Irán
que de trabajar por los intereses nacionales.
Irak es un país rico en petróleo.
Sin embargo, la población no termina de ver
los beneficios del zumo de dinosaurio.
Algo que es evidente si echamos un vistazo
a los presupuestos del Estado iraquí.
(El presupuesto de Irak asciende a unos 90.000
millones de dólares.
En el gráfico podéis ver marcado cómo aproximadamente
dos tercios son engullidos por los sueldos
y pensiones de los trabajadores del sector
público.
Si a eso le suemamos los gastos de capital,
lo cierto es que queda una parte muy reducida
del presupuesto para las inversiones que se
precisan para mejorar el nivel de vida de
los iraquíes.)
Precisamente un sector que necesita inversiones
es el energético.
Por ejemplo, Irak tiene unas reservas de gas
5 veces más grandes que las de Omán.
Sin embargo, su producción es 4 veces menor.
Es una producción tan escasa que apenas cubre
la mitad de consumo del país.
Y la realidad es aún más escandalosa.
Resulta que Irak está quemando buena parte
del gas natural que sale de sus pozos petrolíferos
porque no tiene la infraestructura necesaria
para capturar y aprovechar ese gas.
Entonces, ¿quién es el principal beneficiado
de que Irak necesite importar gas?
Esta jugada no la visteis venir:
(Irak debe a Irán 11.000 millones de dólares
por importaciones de gas, dice el embajador
iraní)
A Irán esto le viene genial.
Porque las sanciones estadounidenses le impiden
exportar sus recursos naturales.
Pero Washington concede exenciones a Irak
porque el país necesita el gas iraní para
cubrir un tercio de su producción de electricidad.
De hecho, cuando hay problemas con el suministro
de gas de Irán, se producen apagones.
Los que veis VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo
ya sabéis que muchas veces repetimos que
los países que no tienen asegurado su suministro
energético tienen muchas dificultades para
que sus sectores económicos prosperen.
Esto lo entiende todo el mundo.
También los iraquíes, que están indignados
al comprobar que sus gobernantes sirven más
a los intereses iraníes que a los del propio
estado.
Sin embargo, esto es algo que está cayendo
por su propio peso.
Y no por una cuestión religiosa, ni mucho
menos.
Como es obvio, los iraquíes se preguntan
qué hace el Gobierno con el récord de ingresos
en 2022 del sector petrolero: 115.000 millones
de dólares ni más ni menos.
Y claro, cuando obtienen las respuestas es
peor.
(“El atraco del siglo”: cómo se saquearon
2.500 millones de dólares de los fondos estatales
iraquíes)
En Irak están de moda los trabajadores fantasma.
No existen, pero cobran sus nóminas.
Vamos, que los gobernantes han engordado ficticiamente
las listas de trabajadores públicos para
meterse sus sueldos en los bolsillos.
Se estima que un 10% de los empleados públicos
son trabajadores fantasma.
Así que, sí, Irak ha evolucionado mucho.
Cada vez es más seguro y hay una democracia.
Pero es un país hipercorrupto.
En otro lugar la gente lo criticaría y diría:
oye, mira qué sinvergüenza este político:
¡se lo ha llevado crudo!
Y ya.
Pero en Irak no es tan sencillo.
El país tiene petróleo por un tubo; técnicamente
su renta per cápita es la de un país como
Jordania.
Sin embargo, el nivel de vida no es equivalente:
los servicios públicos dejan bastante que
desear e incluso sigue habiendo cortes de
electricidad.
Y diréis, bueno, ¿pero esto es tan importante?
Pues hombre, esto es lo que hizo que los talibanes
volvieran a hacerse con el poder en Afganistán.
La gente estaba harta de la corrupción y
de que las instituciones del Estado no funcionaran.
En el caso de Irak, ¿cómo puede cambiar
la situación?
Atentos.
T3(EL ENEMIGO DE MI ENEMIGO)
Los iraquíes ya estallaron contra el Gobierno
iraquí en grandes protestas durante el otoño
de 2019.
Reclamaban el fin de la corrupción y mejores
servicios públicos.
Lograron la dimisión del primer ministro.
Aun así, los manifestantes fueron brutalmente
reprimidos.
Pero no a manos de los cuerpos de seguridad
del Estado, sino de las milicias chiíes que
únicamente rinden cuentas a Irán.
Las mismas que esperaban órdenes del general
Soleimani.
Esta represión pasó factura en 2021 a los
partidos políticos respaldados por Irán,
encabezados por el antiguo primer ministro
Nuri al-Maliki.
El Movimiento Sadrista anunció que buscaría
un Gobierno que excluyera a todas las facciones
proiraníes.
Un Gobierno por y para Irak.
Consiguió importantes aliados para ello:
Masoud Barzani, líder del Kurdistán iraquí,
y Mohammed al-Halbousi, referente de los sunitas
iraquíes.
El propio al-Halbousi se pronunciaba así
de las negociaciones con al-Sadr.
(El tiempo de la interferencia extranjera
en la formación de los gobiernos iraquíes
ha terminado, y hoy las montañas y los desiertos
de Irak se están moviendo hacia el honorable
Najaf para discutir sobre un gobierno iraquí
puramente nacional, ni oriental ni occidental.
Mohammed al-Halbousi)
“Ni este ni oeste” es el slogan favorito
de al-Sadr para describir cómo debe ser el
Gobierno de Irak.
Una procla ma nacionalista iraquí, opuesta
igualmente tanto a las injerencias iraníes
como a las estadou nidenses y que deja atrás
los mandatos religiosos chiíes para construir
un nuevo Irak de la mano de suníes y kurdos.
Ahora bien, mientras tanto, Irán no se mantuvo
de brazos cruzados.
(Irán aumenta la presión sobre los líderes
kurdos y sunitas de Irak para romper la alianza
de Sadr)
Irán ha lanzado ataques con misiles y drones
contra el Kurdistán iraquí.
Asimismo, el Tribunal Supremo de Irak prohibió
las exportaciones de petróleo de esta región
autónoma, dejándola sin su principal fuente
de ingresos.
Respecto a los sunitas, la presión fue ejercida
por parte de las milicias chiíes, que actúan
de forma violenta y con total impunidad en
las áreas de mayoría suní.
En un intento de forzar unas elecciones anticipadas,
Muqtada al-Sadr ordenó dimitir a todos sus
diputados.
Una jugada que ha salido mal.
(Al desaparecer los representantes del Movimiento
Sadrista del Parlamento, sus escaños fueron
ocupados por miembros de los partidos proiraníes.
Estas fuerzas lograron formar un nuevo Gobierno
con Mohamed Shia al Sudani, un antiguo ministro
de al-Maliki.
Los partidarios del Movimiento Sadrista realizaron
protestas en Bagdad que derivaron en enfrentamientos
violentos contra las milicias chiíes respaldadas
por Irán.
Irak estuvo al borde de la guerra civil hasta
que Muqtada al-Sadr ordenó la retirada de
sus seguidores.)
La presión iraní también llega al terreno
religioso.
Una doctrina central en el Islam chiíta es
el concepto de marja.
Significa que cada musulmán chií tiene que
tener un líder espiritual cuyos edictos se
sigan incuestionablemente.
El padre de Muqtada, el ayatolá Mohammed
al-Sadr, sí que tenía las calificaciones
para ser un líder espiritual.
Pero Muqtada no.
Así que, cuando el padre de al-Sadr fue asesinado,
los seguidores del Movimiento Sadrista se
vieron obligados a seguir a otro clérigo
en cuestiones religiosas y recurrieron al
ayatolá al-Haeri.
Es una tarea vitalicia pero… parece que
ya no lo es.
(Al-Haeri se retira de trabajar como autoridad
religiosa y aconseja a los creyentes que sigan
la autoridad de Jamenei en Irán)
Ningún marja renuncia en vida.
Y encima que, siendo un ayatolá iraquí,
reconozca la autoridad religiosa de Jamenei,
el líder supremo de Irán, todo indica que
Teherán influyó en su decisión con el objetivo
de reducir el poder de al-Sadr.
Pero esta jugada para dominar a los partidarios
del Movimiento Sadrista ha fracasado.
Sus seguidores han permanecido leales.
Y el nacionalismo iraquí que antepone los
intereses políticos sobre los religiosos
sale reforzado.
Evidentemente Muqtada al-Sadr no es el aliado
perfecto de Estados Unidos, pero visto lo
visto en Irak, puede ser la opción menos
mala.
Un Irak fuerte gobernado por una coalición
de chiíes, suníes y kurdos que se oponga
al dominio iraní y que permita a Washington
desviar su atención a otras amenazas de mayor
calado como Rusia y China.
No suena mal.
Pero ahora es vuestro turno: ¿Hasta qué
punto puede haber un Irak democrático alejado
de los intereses iraníes?
¿Creéis que la opción de Muqtada al-Sadr
sería beneficiosa para Estados Unidos?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.